right now it is an understatement to say
the real estate market
is hot the median price for an existing
home here in the valley
nearly 350 thousand dollars that is up
about
20 percent from last year so some home
buyers are going to
great lengths to be the first in line
put in that strong offer even if that's
asking you
to sell so we kick off home week with
our i-teams david charns tonight he's
here now with
one young couple's unique tactic yeah
denise and brian this is a pretty unique
you may have seen
these flyers if you live around the
summerlin area a young couple looking to
buy a new home for their growing family
well we found them and we asked them if
it worked
you guys want to play should we play
rob and annie adlerstein are parents to
twin girls
they're temporarily living with family
but finding that perfect home
was an imperfect game in this kind of
situation it seemed almost
impossible to be competitive being
competitive in a housing market where
there's not enough to go around
the next day it sold and to somebody who
gave 20 or 30 over with the cash offer
we looked at
i don't know 30 oh yeah 35 probably over
the last
few months after months of searching and
no luck
they came up with a new plan i would
walk with the twins
the girls it was a way to get out of the
house and i would just
put it on the door flyers asking
homeowners to sell
essentially skirting the market we
really love the look of your home they
say
email us if you're interested have you
ever seen anything where people go to
these lengths
to get a home never truman hopkins is a
real estate agent with urban nest realty
this is how he describes sales right now
insane
for lack of a better term it's just
moving extremely fast
there is very limited number of homes
available there are more buyers
the reason more people are choosing to
call las vegas home
and people are paying an all cash and
above asking price
when i held some open houses there is a
lot of buyers coming from northern
california
to get away from their tight market and
their high inflation of prices
they countered with with ten thousand
dollars over our offer
and they said that if we agree to that
it's ours the adler scenes ended up
buying a home
40 thousand dollars above asking the
flyers
did get a hit but they ended up
purchasing their new home
the old-fashioned way
now this family of four is ready to move
in
weary of a potential bubble burst even
if it takes a big dip
hopefully it'll come back if not quite
this high you know we won't take
a huge loss on it and we'll have lived
there for a good amount of time in a
home that we love
a lot of people getting flyers like that
across the valley so we wanted to tell
you they actually planned to rent that
new home at first to get some of their
money back
now we talked about the average price
for existing homes those are the one
that are already built
342 000 bucks well a new home
will cost you more than that we're
talking about four hundred thousand
dollars so a lot of people wanting to
move here just
not enough inventory i'm david charns
eight news now